تم فعلا اقلاع الطائره الاولى من مطار
ابها الى صنعاء وهي دلوقتي في الطريق
لصنعاء وزملائنا في الطائره مع المحتجزين
السابقين حوالي قرابه 120 محتجز
سابق على متن الطائره على متن الطائره
للطلعه لصنعاء وزي ما حضرتك قلت انه انه
برضو يبقى في طياره تانيه هتطلع من مطار
ابها كمان تقريبا ان شاء الله ساعتين
طالعه برضو من ابها على صناعه تاني دايما
نتحدث في البدايه ولو نقترب قريب قليلا
كيف تمت عمليه
التنظيميه خاصه انكم تشرفون اليوم على
عمليه اتمام نقل الاسرى الحوثيين وهنا من
مطار
ابها الى مطار صنعاء وفي نفس الوقت
في النظام الذي تتبعونه لابد ان يكون هناك
ايضا طائره متزامنه ومن مدينه اخرى او من
مطار اخر طيب دعني الاول انه العمليه
اللوجستيه معقده للغايه اوكي لانه زي ما
انت قلت في طائرات تانيه متزامنه في طائره
برضو طالعه من صنعاء هتوصل ان شاء الله في
الرياض تحمل برضو 20 محتاجه السابق وده
طبعا بالتزامن مع الطائره اللي طالعه من
مطار ابها وفي في اربع مدن في اليمن برضو
يعني يتم نقل وتيسير
النقل يعني نقل وتيسير الافراج عن
المحتجازين السابقين دوله في في وقت واحد
هي العمليات الافراج تستمر على مدار ثلاث
ايام والتلات ايام دي احنا النهارده من
السعوديه وبقيت وامبارح كنا من يمن ننقل
من اليمن من
داخل المدن اليمنيه وبكره كمان برضو هيبقى
من داخل المدن اليمنيه والمدن اليمنيه
احنا عندنا طواقم في صنعاء عدن المخه
والمغرب اجمل عدد المحتجزين بحسب ما
وصلتكم من
اللائحه للمحتجزين من كلا الطرفين النزاع
الشرعيه وايضا كم عددهم الاجماع اللي احنا
ان شاء الله النهارده يعني النهارده هننصر
من ابها
افراجهم يعني هيبقوا 237 ولكن على مدار
التلات ايام دول
قرابه 900 محتاجه سيتم اطلاق سراحهم
وافراج عنهم طيب اذا هناك قرابه 900 محتجز
هي اجمالي المراحل الثلاث اذا صح التعبير
ان نتحدث ذلك ولكن اليوم هناك
237 سوف يغادر من مطار الى صنعاء دارينا
نتحدث عن ايضا الطائره الثانيه الاولى
كانت 120 اذا 117 سوف ينتقلون الى الطائره
الثانيه
طواقم اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر بتبقى
معاهم تتاكد طبعا من صحتهم على متن
الطائره وبنوصلهم لحد
السلطات هناك الاحمر السعودي ايضا اليوم
كان يرافق في عمليه ايضا المحتجزين تمام
احنا والهلال الاحمر السعودي ابناء حركه
دوليه واحده فطبعا الهلال الاحمر السعودي
كان دورهم مهم جدا كان فيه طواقم صحيه
كمان من عندهم ومتطوعين من الهلال الاحمر
السعودي كانوا متواجدين معانا تاني
بيساعدونا ان احنا
يعني تيسير انه المحتجزين السابقين يطلعوا
على الطائره وانه لو احتاجوا اي حاجه صحيه
برده يبقوا موجودين عشان يلبوها
هناك واجهتم اي عوائق في مطار ابها او
ايضا في المطارات داخل اليمن سواء في
المرحله الاولى يوم امس او ايضا في الريح
المتزامة
بالامانه انا هتكلم على الشق اللوجستي
فالشق اللوجستي زي ما انا قلت لك التزامن
مع الاوقات بتاعه الطيران نفسها هو ده
اللي بسبب يعني نوعا ما عرقاله يعني من
السنه انها تطلع قبل تطلع بعد بس الحمد
لله في التوقيت فقط بس عمليه تنظيميه داخل
المطار لا الحمد لله لا ما واجهنا في مطار
ابها
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات